[Music]
my name is Kevin belted and on the
deputy me of the lawmaker register
council and we've just finished their
March monthly council meeting we don't
often have large galleries of public at
our meetings that today we did and they
were here because they are interested in
one of the items on the agenda which was
to do with a proposed quarry is a
council we have not yet received any
applications for resource consent for
the quarry but the residence and
obviously very concerned that when that
application does come in at the council
a process that and we know that what
could been some important or what
happens as a council there's not a lot
we can do about it until we've actually
got an application to address another
item of interest with them there the
council's annual plan for 2017 18 year
and the item on the agenda was to adopt
that annual plane for public
consultation the main interest of pulse
of the public will be that it proposes a
three point eight percent general rate
rise or it's a rise across the district
of our rates but it's an ethical average
really because a lot of different
properties it will have different rate
rises right across the district it is
important part of their annual plan is
actually we're asking people's opinion
on whether the council should have a
policy for trading on Easter Sunday
submissions open on the 10th March and
they will close on the 11th of April
we also considered a report on
alternatives for our three water's
rating we're talking about our water
supply public water supply drinkable
water supply also our less water sewer
schemes and also s in the in the storm
water so we have targeted rates for
those services across the district at
the moment and it's a proposal to set up
a working party of the council that will
look at a possible alternative to our
current targeted rating system one
outcome could be that we have rates
right across the district for all our
water supplies and all our service
schemes and all their storm water
schemes the same rate right across the
district another report that was
discussing something council was a the
naming old found a war plan and [ __ ]
away now we're about to start process of
constructing walk and cycle ways between
the township of regular and what end and
when also between ring your own card boy
the name of that walkway is proposed to
be the Passchendaele memorial walkway
cycleway mates to recognize the
relationship between ian relationship
that and when mercury district council
has listed on a becky council and
Belgium and Passchendaele it's
particularly important this year because
the centenary of the Passchendaele
battle that will be commemorated in
October this year and the council has a
delegation going to their commemoration
ceremony and I'm Taylor
[Music]
you